SEREN DAVIES: I'm Seren.
I'm an accessibility
advocate, nail art lover,
and a huge fan of unicorns,
and this is how I code.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I wrote a really
cool Chrome extension
which assessed websites to
see how dyslexic friendly
they were.
I developed a really cool
little dropdown box with areas
they could improve, like
not using icon fonts
and choosing to
not use bold text.
It meant a lot to me because I
want to make the world a better
place.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When I edit CSS
files, I usually do
things like change
the border of boxes
and change the colors
of different elements.
And I don't usually
want that bit.
I usually want one or two
lines that actually do the job.
So when I come to
commit it, I use
git add -p to make
sure that I'm only
adding the one or two lines and
none of the other weird funky
bits.
I'm Seren.
I'm a nail art advocate?
[LAUGHTER]